hey this is John Delaney with a Ramsey
Network you know I'm getting sick of
hearing new normal the words new normal
are starting to give me the
heebie-jeebies and the hives all the
things all of the things am i getting
from the phrase the new normal you know
why because normal stupid it never
exists right and every day is different
than the day before unless you get stuck
in a routine and then that's your fault
and your problem okay so I'm not
interested in anybody I know and love or
myself being normal
why because normal got us in all the
crazy normal got us in tons of student
loan debt and normal got us super lonely
not a lot of friends none out of
community
normal got us where we have distracted
ourselves so much we didn't have our
feelings anymore and what we end up
doing is shoving all this stuff down
into our souls into our feet until our
booties it's just we're getting crushed
by it and then we walk around and carry
this normal all day all the time and
it's killing us it's wearing us out so
instead of new normal
why just stop being so dramatic and
asked ourselves what have we learned
what have we learned I'm always saying
you choose only two things you choose
your thoughts and you choose your
actions that's it all right and so what
do we learn we learn that we carry a lot
of garbage around with us all the time I
got this in the mail the other day and
it was super rad we had a caller on the
Dave Ramsey show and this woman called
and she was talking about how frustrated
she was with her husband how frustrated
she was to still be paying off debts for
so long how frustrated she was that for
a decade she wouldn't be a stay-at-home
mom and she didn't get to live out that
dream because she had to go to work and
pay off debts and she had this picture
for her life was gonna be and it didn't
end up materializing and she just wanted
help with how exhausted she was which
meant she wanted help with how
frustrated and angry she was
which meant she wanted to know how to
stop carrying all this baggage around
and so we talked to her and she sent us
a note she sent me in Dave a note and
she sent this stuff in this bag and man
this is one of coolest things I've ever
received
she crocheted the word regret she
crocheted the word anger she crocheted
the word resentment and what she did was
she took a lot of time to feel these
feelings to own them to create them to
write them down and then she literally
put them in a bag and mailed them
halfway across the country and said I'm
not carrying this anymore and then in
her note she said when she decided to do
this when she decided to take control of
her thoughts and then she decided to act
she said her marriage was already better
one week later just because she decided
I'm not carrying this stuff anymore
her new normal is gonna be a lot lighter
she's gonna move through the world with
more grace and more kindness she's gonna
love her husband so there is no new
normal
every day you decide here's what I'm
gonna be today here's what's I can
guarantee you we're gonna have
frustrations we're gonna have
resentments you're gonna get mad you're
gonna get angry
you're gonna go without you're gonna be
exhausted you're gonna be frustrated
tomorrow you're gonna wake up and decide
don't want to carry that around or do I
want to put it in a bag and set it down
or better yet ship it halfway across the
country if you have cash that you'd like
to put in the bag and ship halfway
across the country I'll take that too
but you get to decide what are you gonna
carry you choose your thoughts you
choose your actions this is dr. John
Delaney with Ramsey Network thanks for
joining us hit the subscribe button
follow me at the John de Loney's use the
little uh Napoleon Dynamite butterfly
paper thing to send it to your friends
this works I love you take care I'll see
you tomorrow bye